[Musique]
j'ai quand même promis que le monde
était là pour l'aider
que la vie parce qu'il voulait vivre
Martin mais Martin Collard 36 ans est
mort devant les portes de l'hôpital de
septile où il voulait juste qu'on l'aide
et une joie de vivre puis
[Musique]
j'ai rien fait de mal pourquoi les
policiers c'est pas ton criminel typique
c'est quelqu'un qui est en détresse on
s'entend il n'était pas dans son état
normal mais vous allez voir comment une
intervention policière peut rapidement
tourner au drame si vous intervenez trop
vite vous risquez de vous retrouver dans
une situation où les résultats peuvent
être mauvais vraiment mauvais on va
revivre cette intervention de minutes en
minutes ça ébranle sérieusement la
version officielle
n'aime pas revenir devant l'hôpital de
cette île
ce lieu était jamais associé pour elle
aux souvenirs de son frère étendu au sol
sans vie
il y avait un visage qui me disait tout
de suite Martin ne vit plus le cœur de
Martin s'est arrêté pendant que deux
agents de la Sûreté du Québec tentait de
le maîtriser ni le coronaire ni
l'enquête indépendante qui a suivi non
condamné l'intervention policière
mais la famille a des doutes
[Applaudissements]
c'est un overdose qui a fait puis moi je
me disais
ça a aucun bon sens je veux pas qu'il
dire en gros c'est juste la peur des
policiers c'est juste la peur de
l'hôpital
chose que ça passait du début de son
histoire aller que Martin soit d'un lit
d'hôpital et tubé
encore aujourd'hui après 6 ans et demi
que mon frère est décédé comme ça
martin est un bon vivant mon comique mon
clown
[Musique]
Martin Collard 36 ans vient d'une
famille tricotée serrée il était proche
de sa sœur Gaetane les deux se parlaient
presque tous les jours et prenez soin de
moi-même c'était le petit frère c'est le
matin n'importe quand qui travaillait
pas le matin il vient d'importer mon
petit café
au moment des faits Martin mène une vie
tranquille travaille depuis 10 ans pour
la compagnie minière iOS et il vient de
rompre avec son ami de coeur
il y avait de la peine cette fin de
semaine extrêmement
très grosse peine d'amour très grosse
peine d'amour mon frère
et
il traverse un moment difficile ce soir
d'octobre 2015 Gaëtane et sa tante
Thérèse passe la soirée avec lui il dit
mais c'est pas j'attends juste que vous
partez pour boirer ma porte puis de me
coucher puis dormir puis demain on sort
tout le monde ensemble enfin qu'on a dit
on est parti
puis en pleine nuit le téléphone sonne
chez Gaetane
quand j'ai vu le numéro j'ai fait ok
au téléphone je demande sa voiture
Martin non ça va pas vraiment tu es où
tu es où
Martin est dans un bar rue Brochu il a
consommé de la cocaïne et se sent mal je
dis Martin
Martin se plaint de palpitations sur le
conseil de sa sœur il part à pied vers
l'hôpital il me dit
est-ce que tu me juges la tête
de ta fille de la petite que je veux
vivre si je veux à l'hôpital que je vais
vivre chez le P oui Martin
c'est certain
j'ai quand même promis que le monde
était là pour l'aider
que la vie parce qu'il voulait vivre
Martin
pauvre Martin
pour décortiquer la suite des événements
nous avons fait appel à deux experts
le détective chords de MC a travaillé 30
ans au service de police de Los Angeles
il est un pionnier en Amérique du Nord
dans la formation des policiers en
intervention de crise
Michael aruda ex policier ou SPVM
pendant 25 ans aujourd'hui formateur est
un des très rares experts reconnus dans
ce type d'intervention au Québec
l'élément clé est cette vidéo captée par
la caméra de surveillance de l'hôpital
la famille a mis des années à l'obtenir
dans le cadre d'une poursuite qu'elle a
entreprises allons-y
[Musique]
aux alentours de 4 heures alerté par le
bruit des employés découvrent Martin
devant la porte principale au lieu de
celle de l'urgence
alors Martin arrive de la rue Évangéline
se présente là l'urgence est ici on peut
présumer qui cherche un endroit pour
rentrer
une infirmière demande à Martin de
contourner le bâtiment pour se rendre à
l'urgence Gaëtan est toujours au
téléphone avec lui et capte une partie
des échanges
[Musique]
Martin gesticule crie dit que l'hôpital
va exploser et commence à enlever son
pantalon combien de personnes qu'on sait
que qui crie à 4h du matin qui
t'entraîne se déshabiller au milieu de
la rue qui effectivement tient des
propos incohérents c'est quelque chose
qui va pas c'est pas ton criminel
typique c'est quelqu'un qui est en
détresse
on voit l'infirmière qui décide de faire
appel à la police c'est le premier point
tournant de la soirée
c'est le moment où elle appelle la
police elle se tient entre les deux
portes
d'abord pourquoi appeler la police il
vient pour de l'aide et la police se
pointe dans son esprit ça change
complètement la dynamique
l'appel à la centrale décrit une
personne en détresse psychologique blanc
5 pieds 8 gilet noir cellulaire
casquette probablement plus de pantalons
avec un peu d'informations qu'on a déjà
on sait qu'on s'envoie dans une
intervention ou un appel pour une
personne en détresse on sait que c'est
pas quelque chose de de qui met là de
danger ce que c'est quelqu'un qui est
dérangeant plus que dangereux on est en
train de déjà faire des scénarios
pendant que les policiers sont en route
les employés parviennent presque à
convaincre Martin d'entrer de son plein
gré selon ce que nous a affirmé au moins
une des personnes qui étaient sur place
à ses yeux Martin n'avait rien de
menaçant mais la tension augmente
subitement quand deux agents de la
Sûreté un homme et une femme arrivent
sur les lieux Martin est toujours au
téléphone avec sa tante Thérèse qui a
pris la relève
Martin dit je l'entendais ce matin des
policiers j'ai rien fait de mal pourquoi
les policiers ils comprenaient pas qu'il
y a une demander de l'aide à l'hôpital
puis les premiers qui voient arriver
c'est les policiers
c'est normal pour lui d'être inquiet ou
d'avoir peur en général quand les
policiers arrivent ce n'est pas pour
vous offrir une carte cadeau
qui arrive en temps normal de façon
générale le taux d'anxiété d'un citoyen
qui est pas en situation de crise il y a
un stress qui va augmenter mais
imaginez-vous quelqu'un qui est déjà
dans un état de panique
le policier explique dans des documents
de cours qu'il a essayé de jaser avec
Martin mais que celui-ci refuse de dire
son nom comme s'il se foutait de moi un
peu il ne me regardait pas
quand une personne est en crise nous
devons être plus patients nous devons
ralentir les choses on va essayer de
désescalader ramener la personne dans un
état qu'on peut se parler l'objectif
c'est de rassurer quelqu'un un
intervention association crise ne dure
pas des minutes ça peut durer des heures
ça peut durer quelques heures
mais le policier dit avoir peur que
Martin s'enfuit
on va le laisser promener ça prend le
temps que ça prend il y a pas d'urgence
de Gear
bien que des renforts soient déjà en
route sans attendre le arrivé un des
agents intervient il saisit Martin par
le bras c'est quelque chose qu'on
enseigne et qu'on dit puis qu'on répète
on a tous jamais quelqu'un qui est en
crise on touche jamais quelqu'un qui est
en crise parce qu'on sait jamais comment
être la personne va réagir
l'intervention policière vient de
prendre un nouveau tournant qui sera
fatale
après la pause les policiers vont
employer une technique très controversée
de mort de pleurs de plats
qui reste dans la mémoire
la police vient d'arriver devant
l'hôpital de septile et rappelons que
Martin est là pour recevoir des soins il
n'a pas commis de crimes il ne menace
personne alors comment se fait-il que
les policiers interviennent de façon
aussi musclée
[Musique]
au Québec au moins le quart des
interactions avec la police implique des
gens dont l'état mental est altéré comme
pour Martin drogue et police peuvent
devenir un dangereux cocktail on le sait
que ce phénomène-là existe depuis au
moins 30 ans c'est arrivé avec la faire
corsic
[Musique]
le joueur de Hakim est mort hier soir à
Québec dans des circonstances
troublantes
et des Nordiques mort en 1992 au cours
d'une intervention policière musclée
c'était les premières fois qu'on voit
suite à l'intervention policière avec
quelqu'un qui avait consommé qui est en
état de panique et dans l'état
d'excitation on voyait déjà le ces
symptômes blancs comment intervenir
faire attention quand on rencontre
quelqu'un qui est dans cet état là
revoici Martin agité et sans son
pantalon en hyperthermie des signes
manifestent d'intoxication puis sans
raison apparente la vidéo s'interrompt
ça arrivera souvent
quand elle reprend 8 minutes plus tard
les policiers sont sur place l'un d'eux
CESI Martin par le bras quand le poils
Martin s’éloigne à deux coins de rue
suivi par les deux policiers
le personnel en profite pour rentrer
vêtements et chaussures de Martin à
l'intérieur il s'attendent manifestement
ce que les policiers amènent Martin à
l'urgence
dehors Martin s'est arrêté à
l'intersection de l'avenue Gamache il
s'accroche toujours à sa sœur au bout du
fil
je le Martin Martin ça va bien à l'écart
passe-moi les policiers pense moi un
policier je veux parler à quelqu'un
réussite à parler aux policiers et à
prévenir qu'elle s'en vient on se
parlait mais mon dessin on ange lui dit
j'ai dit que il était en peine dans mon
j'ai expliqué le tout il était triste et
il y avait consommé imaginez-vous
l'information que vous venez de me
donner là je sais dans quel état je
connais son nom son prénom son nom de
famille je connais c'est quoi pourquoi
qui est de même le délément de
déclencheur de la crise
rupture amoureuse il y a consommé de la
cocaïne et tomentale perturbé
selon l'expert le policier rate ici une
occasion de créer un lien de confiance
il redonne le téléphone à Martin après
ça
plus rien comme si
écoute il y a même pas dit merci il y a
rien dit dans la seconde dans le 2
secondes j'ai entendu un cri de mort de
pleurs de plats
qui reste dans la mémoire
puis pour moi c'est là que ça ça
c'est le moment où le policier a essayé
de prendre le bras de Martin pour le
retenir une deuxième fois puis j'ai
échappé la prise d'utile il m'a glissé
des mains
il n'a pas réussi devant l'hôpital je ne
sais pas pourquoi il a pensé qu'il
aurait plus de succès à l'attraper dans
la rue surtout sans l'aide de renfort
Martin repart les deux policiers assez
trousse ami et Thibault observe la scène
depuis son balcon en face
j'entendais quelqu'un qui courait dans
la rue puis des gens qui criaient puis
on s'est levé c'est là qu'on a vu qu'il
y avait un homme qui courait dans le
stationnement et il y avait une
policière qui courait derrière lui elle
voulait qu'il s'arrête se mobilisent
puis la personne semble être plus en
panique puis elle est très vous laisse
et s'enfuir elle voulait pas s'arrêter
là dangereux ce monsieur là du tout pas
du tout
le policier décrit la suite Martin court
en direction de l'hôpital il tentait
d'ouvrir les portes verrouillées je lui
ai fait une encolure
la brutalité du geste a suscité ce
commentaire d'un témoin qui habitait en
face c'est là que le temps a changé le
flex est mis à lui crier après puis il
s'est jeté dessus un sauvage pour le
maîtriser
[Musique]
quand la vidéo reprend les deux hommes
sont déjà par terre on ne sait pas
depuis combien de temps il y a des
jambes qui t'entraînent de bouger il est
en mode survie il veut se débarque il
veut sortir dehors
le policiers admettra avoir utilisé son
poids pour maîtriser Martin au sol en
maintenant l'encolure l'encolure vise à
exercer une pression sur les artères
carotides pour provoquer une perte de
conscience en moins de 15 secondes mais
sur la bande vidéo Martin reste
conscient il tente de se dégager de
toutes ses forces
[Musique]
si l'étranglement carotidien était bien
fait il ne pourrait pas donner de coup
de pied il se serait évanoui
le risque est de bloquer les voies
respiratoires
moi je personnellement juste une
technique que j'aurais jamais suggéré à
qui que ça soit de l'appliquer auprès
d'une personne surtout sur une personne
qui est en crise
ce qui est malheureux c'est que si vous
maintenez l'étranglement carotidien plus
de 30 secondes
à une minute il y a une perte de la
fonction cérébrale
Martin lutte pendant au moins deux
longues minutes à 4h20 et 2 secondes sur
la vidéo c'est la dernière fois qu'on
voit Martin Gouget puis la vidéo
s'interrompt à nouveau
Gaetane n'a jamais raccroché elle a
déposé le téléphone le temps de se
préparer à partir quand elle reprend le
combiné elle entend des mots qu'il a
entre
tout de suite que un agent crie à mon
frère Martin et Martin ça criait Martin
entendu puis que la panique et le dit
après nous a Raphaël lui la SPA de ton
plus
désemparé
vite vite quand je la porte je pars
l'espume c'est la police autochtone la
seule disponible pour venir en confort
ce soir-là à leur arrivée l'un d'eux me
note Martin toujours sous contrainte en
le retournant tout de suite il reconnaît
Martin un ami d'enfance qui vient de son
village et constate qu'il ne respire
plus
on entendait le policier qui disait à
Martin reste avec nous reste avec nous
l'âge nous pas le matin puis après cela
s'est aperçue que les gens l'observaient
sentiez-vous beaucoup de tension vous
étiez paniquée on vient de se rendre
compte qu'il ne respire plus on est on a
sauté deux minutes à peu près
rapidement ça c'est un des renforts s'en
va vers l'urgence en espérant trouver de
l'aide policière numéro 2 qui est dans
un état d'énervement important on sent
qu'elle est extrêmement inquiète je
pense
par radio la policière demande l'aide
d'un médecin ou d'une infirmière parce
que l'homme n'est plus là
[Musique]
dehors on commence les manœuvres de
réanimation
le policier parti chercher de l'aide
revient bredouille
nouvelle interruption de la bande vidéo
c'est là que Gayton arrive à son tour
sur les lieux qui était couché sur le
balcon en boxeur sur le ciment les mains
derrière me noter
je vais mis à genoux
je voulais être très il y avait un
visage qui me disait tout de suite il y
a plus rien Martin ne vit plus
4h26 on discerne sur la vidéo qui
redémarre la présence de l'infirmière
revenue sur les lieux avec un préposé et
un gardien de sécurité mais elle était
comme dessemparée
la policière te laisse cul a répondu en
panique qui est en arrêt cardio
respiratoire c'est pas c'est un code de
médecin c'est un médecin qu'on veut
quand l'infirmière demande l'aide du
personnel de l'urgence on lui répond on
ne sort pas parce qu'on n'a pas le droit
alors j'ai demandé à la gente sécurité
dit-elle puis au préposé d'aller me
chercher une civière
puis par après on a vu les secouristes
qui sont venus avec une civière ils ont
fait le tour de la porte d'urgence et on
passe le garage ils sont venus jusqu'à 9
ans c'est quand qu'ils ont bougé pour le
mettre sur la civière a dit je peux pas
faire de massage avec des menottes
avec quelqu'un qui qui a des malades
dans le dos au niveau respiratoires de
pomper quelqu'un ça peut causer plus de
dommages que d'autres choses
[Musique]
Martin arrive finalement à l'urgence à
4h34
dans son rapport le gardien de sécurité
écrit que le médecin a sauvé le patient
mais Martin a manqué d'oxygène trop
longtemps
il ne reprendra jamais conscience
et sera débranché trois jours plus tard
[Musique]
au retour le rôle de l'hôpital soulève
aussi de sérieuses questions
je crois que l'hôpital a failli à ses
obligations envers Martin il était sur
leur terrain en appelant la police on
introduit un potentiel de force mortelle
[Musique]
c'est en semaine dans la peau des
policiers on peut tous admettre qui sont
exposés à des situations extrêmes que
les problèmes de santé mentale les voies
de proches souvent mais comment se
fait-il alors que des experts qu'il y a
de la recherche scientifique sérieuse
qui se fait sur les meilleurs pratiques
la façon de maîtriser une personne qu'on
est encore recours à une technique aussi
controversée
[Musique]
celle qui tient la caméra c'est la fille
de Martin
elle avait 14 ans quand elle a perdu son
père son grand complice
je m'ennuie tellement de toi et
Christelle dans une publication Facebook
surtout de nourrir à tue-tête
Martin garder son enfant
pratiquement seul dans ces temps-là
c'est avec l'aide d'entourage mais je
sais que maman est comme papa
Martin c'était sa vie c'était sa fille
mon cadeau à moi m'a été enlevé son
préavis et avec force écrit la jeune
fille jamais je me remettrai de ta perte
la famille Collard reste avec beaucoup
de questions plusieurs règles de
l'intervention de crise semblent avoir
été empreinte sans que personne ne soit
tenu responsable
il y a des procédures dans les guides
des pratiques policières qui viennent du
ministère de la Sécurité publique
l'objectif c'est toujours de l'amener à
l'urgence sans jamais utiliser la force
[Musique]
et ces procédures les voici
une personne en délire agitée comme des
agents des criminants risquent de
décéder subitement pendant ou après un
effort physique il faut privilégier la
désescalade faire appel à des renforts
éviter d'appliquer une pression sur son
dos la placer en position latérale afin
d'éviter l'asphyxie tout pour ne pas
mettre sa vie en danger
[Musique]
c'est une urgence médicale alors on doit
avoir un plan on doit savoir comment va
l'amener à l'urgence c'est très
important de disposer de ressources
suffisantes si vous intervenez trop vite
vous risquez de vous retrouver dans une
situation où les résultats peuvent être
mauvais vraiment mauvais
mais moins de 10 minutes se sont écoulés
entre l'arrivée des policiers et le
moment où l'un d'eux décide à lui seul
de maîtriser Martin
minimum de 4 à 5 policiers pour
effectivement pour qu'on puisse
contrôler chacun des membres c'est à
dire les jambes les la tête les deux
bras
[Musique]
évitez la lutte qui oblige Martin à
déployer des efforts physiques dangereux
pour son cœur affecté par la cocaïne
[Musique]
plus de force qu'on met sur l'individu
plus l'individu va se débattre plus
d'efforts que ça prend plus qu'un danger
que la personne de cette par la suite
on comprime aussi sa poitrine sa
respiration ce qui peut aggraver un
problème médical potentiel
l'encolure appliquée ici par des
policiers en formation correspondent à
un niveau de force puissant
habituellement limité au cas d'agression
potentiellement mortelles
on utilise l'étranglement carotidien en
dernier recours
quand une vie est menacée
j'ai lu les directives de la Sûreté du
Québec
et c'est ce qui est indiqué
dans ce cas-ci c'était loin d'être son
dernier recours il y a beaucoup d'autres
outils qui l'auraient pu utiliser pour
prendre le contrôle
le policier a considéré que Martin était
potentiellement dangereux et qu'il
n'était pas capable de le menotter en
raison de sa résistance c'est la
résistance pour quelqu'un qui pense
qu'il va mourir si je pense que je vais
mourir vous allez voir que n'importe qui
n'importe qui citoyen va se débattre
le policier n'avait jamais fait
d'encolure en 5 ans de métiers ni reçu
de mise à jour depuis sa formation
initiale sa partenaire ne l'avait jamais
utilisé non plus en 28 ans de carrière
au niveau de la désescalade au niveau de
l'intervention de crise au niveau de la
communication malheureusement
il y a très peu de service de police qui
donne cette formation là au policier on
laisse les policiers patrouilleurs à
eux-mêmes à dire des bruits
à faire et malheureusement c'est des
situations qu'on voit
malgré ses ratés le Directeur des
poursuites criminels et pénales à
estimer que les policiers n'avaient pas
eu d'autres choix que de maîtriser
Martin par la force
il sait plus entre autres sur l'enquête
réalisée par la police de Québec
cette enquête fait état de ce formulaire
où le policier a coché que Martin avait
un couteau il y avait bien un coup de
pêche parmi ses vêtements dont il s'est
débarrassé rapidement sur le perron de
l'hôpital et qu'on a ramassé
rappelez-vous bien avant que les
policiers tentent de le maîtriser
peut-être on irait voir
plus loin qu'on aurait écouté peut-être
d'autres gens qui avaient eu d'autres
choses à dire qu'on aurait peut-être
laisser l'histoire un petit peu
sortir un peu
la famille se demande pourquoi des
témoins comme cet employé qu'on voit
observer la scène longuement non pas été
rencontrés par les enquêteurs Amélie
Thibault n'a pas été interrogé non plus
j'ai jamais rencontré un policière ce
sujet-là est-ce que vous vous attendiez
ce qui vient de vous voir ben ça aurait
été en quelque sorte normal puisque on
était témoin direct
le rapport d'autopsie discute aussi les
policiers en déclarant trait improbable
que l’intervention policière est
contribuée à l'arrêt cardio-respiratoire
le pathologiste conclut que la cocaïne
et la cause du décès trois experts
médicaux retenus par la famille conteste
ses conclusions
[Musique]
je sais à vous dire mon total des
accords à cette affirmation la cause de
la recardiaque est multifactorielle la
France très improbable que
l'intervention policière est contribuée
de quelques façons et grossièrement
trompeuse et
erronée
ces experts sont unanimes et si les
policiers avaient été témoins agressifs
écrits l'un d'eux Martin serait-il resté
conscient oui l'hôpital n'est pas
épargné non plus c'est Monsieur Collard
avait eu accès aux urgences dès à son
arrivée serait-il en vie aujourd'hui
réponse
oui
je crois que l'hôpital a failli à ses
obligations envers Martin il était sur
leur terrain en appelant la police on
introduit un potentiel de force mortelle
et rappelez-vous aussi que le personnel
de l'urgence a refusé de porter secours
à Martin alors qu'il était en arrêt
cardio-respiratoire
craignant que les assurances n'allaient
pas les couvrir à l'extérieur des murs
de l'hôpital une légende urbaine
explique l'infirmière qui est sorti
quand même et qui s'est fait dire par
des collègues qu'elle n'aurait pas dû
c'est une fausse croyance il faut sortir
je faisais quelqu'un et un malaise c'est
pas vrai que tu peux t'abonner
elle a raison les directives du
ministère de la santé sont claires la
responsabilité de l'hôpital envers le
patient débute dès que ce dernier a
entre sur son terrain le ci3s de la côte
nord a décliné notre demande d'entrevue
mais affirme que Martin a reçu tous les
soins requis
pas finir de même si elle est un ovodo
ils sont en seconde
Martin fait maintenant partie des
statistiques
entre 2006 et 2015 17 personnes sont
mortes sous contrainte lors d'une
intervention policière comme Martin
toutes les victimes avaient consommé des
stimulants neuf fois sur 10 on a conclu
que la drogue était l'unique cause du
décès
je pense que la majorité des policiers
incluant ceux qui font des enquêtes il y
a une méconnaissance au niveau de
l'intervention pré des personnes qui ont
des problèmes de santé mentale
et le cas de Martin n'est sans doute pas
unique
longtemps qu'on n'a pas changé nos
façons de faire que les organismes les
services de police on prend bien compris
on peut bien saisir qu'est-ce qu'on
devrait faire malheureusement c'est pas
un colis qui vont en avoir d'autres
vous n'êtes pas seul c'est un défi les
tragédie sont aussi des occasions pour
s'améliorer il ne faut pas voir ça comme
un blâme mais plutôt comme une
opportunité d'effectuer des changements
pour qu'un autre cas comme celui de
Martin ne se reproduit jamais
le procureur général du Québec a admis
qu'en rétrospective l'intervention
policière n'est pas entièrement conforme
aux règles de l'art mais continue
d'affirmer qu'elle n'a pas causé de
préjudice à Martin Collard la Sûreté du
Québec a décliné notre demande
d'entrevue
je sais que c'était pour voulu mais ça
m'a viré ça aurait été tellement simple
d'avoir vos détails la mémoire Martin
sera toujours là mais on n'aurait pas
toutes ces questionnements cette
tristesse et à vivre avec ça encore
en poursuivant la police et l'hôpital de
cette île la famille espère que toute la
lumière soit faite sur les circonstances
de sa mort
c'est la fin d'une vie c'est
pour vouloir que ça soit un commencement
à d'autres choses
mais il faut qu'on passe une étape faut
qu'on pense
[Musique]